hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
i am just checking in
on you just checking in to see
how the hell you're doing on this
wonderful friday that also happens to be
saint patrick's day
oh the legend
the legend of saint patrick i'm looking
it up right now what happened did he
chase the rats out of [ __ ] town so
everybody could go back to boozing in
peace
what happened
the legend of saint patrick there are
many legends associated with the life of
saint patrick
according to one he miraculously drove
all the snakes
of ireland into the sea
he is said to have used the three
leaflets of the shamrock to explain the
concept of the holy trinity
the holy trinity is that garlic onions
and something else in new orleans
he reportedly raised as many as 33
people from the dead
oh this he's like irish jesus
except typical irish guy he didn't do it
for himself like jesus did the selfish
hippie he did it for other people
he did it for other people and then they
were like patty saint say patty you all
right and he's just like yeah i'm good
well don't you want to [ __ ] live
forever
no
no i'm fine
now i'm fine laddie
you just go on and you're [ __ ]
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do um
anyway happy st patrick's day to
everybody uh if you're smart
oh [ __ ] my kid's taking a nap sorry if
you're smart
um you know and you're of a certain age
you'll stay out of the bars
i mean this is just a [ __ ] show
people just they should be you know you
go to a bowling alley they give you
bowling shoes like this is the day they
should just you should come in check
your shoes and you get a pair of shoes
to puke in
right the old pukin loafers
has a number on the back every number
says zero
um
yeah i'm not gonna lie to you i used to
go out on st patrick's day and uh
but i didn't not very long
by my late 20s i was just like all right
this is [ __ ] stupid
you know this is the valentine this is
valentine's day for alcoholics
wherever you can't get a [ __ ] seat
everything's booked up there's a line
everywhere it's a big [ __ ] pain in
the ass everybody's dressed like an
[ __ ] it's the exact same thing
um
why don't i go out boozing on the 18th
when i can get a seat when everybody's
hungover same thing right celebrate your
relationship on february 15th the 16th
although i think the restaurants are
starting to get a little wise to it
but they can't really justify it yet
i think eventually they're going to move
it to valentine's week
spelt w-e-a-k
but fortunately you know most of the
women that i've been talking to they're
all like yeah i think it's [ __ ]
stupid
um
let's check this out here
wait does that mean there's no snakes in
[ __ ] ireland
are there
well since saint patty left they all
came back are there any snakes
in ireland well that's a nice setup for
a joke
yeah talk to my neighbor all right
ireland is one of many countries where
there are no snakes
wow they must be fascinated by those
[ __ ] things there's snakes in my
country and i [ __ ] i'm freaked out by
them
you can't tell where they're going you
know what i mean they got too many moves
you just got to stare at the head you
know the running back you just you know
you just look at their hips
aim for that [ __ ] don't don't go for the
head movement the snake's the exact
opposite
right
[ __ ] sidewinder looking at you he's
going to the side
um
they got to have something called the
snake killer right big goddamn pole with
a [ __ ] meat cleaver on it
um
no snakes in ireland isn't that amazing
i guess they can't swim huh
they must have missed the boat
because according to uh
you know these [ __ ] people here
whatever you call them
the people that actually study like land
what do you call those people
landscapers
horticulturists no smarter than a
landscaper smarter than a horticulturist
smarter than a paleontologist they they
like hang with paleontology
paleontologists like they give each
other a little tip of the cat and i
think they look down
on horticulturalists botanist
landscapers
like landscapers are the cigarette
smokers of people that work with the
land
you know despite i feel their work is
displayed
more often than anybody else's
you know what i mean but then i think
that kind of means you're more like that
andy warhol guy
who i have to tell you it's just i i
don't get that [ __ ] at all
it's a soup can i'm commenting on the
[ __ ]
capitalism oh that's fantastic andy
that's amazing
um you got anything else would you would
you paint a coat hanger
with we love our customers on it
um
painfully
i'm going look i went after gingerbread
i'm [ __ ] i'm trying to get
controversial here man i'm trying to get
more listeners
all right i went after dead [ __ ]
ginger baker a couple weeks ago now i'm
going after dead andy warhol i will tell
you the one thing i do feel for andy
warhol is some psycho chick shot him and
really went to jail for like [ __ ] you
know a year or so and that was it and
then years later he died from
complications from those gunshots
um
although i don't know you talked to so
many people that hung out with him he
said he said he was a bit of a toxic
[ __ ] but that doesn't mean that some
what was it she called the scum
manifesto that's what it was
you know what i mean this is back when
the you know if they just had social
media back then she could have just
tried to cancel them through like you
know twitter
or something but back then
you know if you were an angry white
woman you had to take the matters into
your own hands
and even then you still got treated like
a white chick
i know what a lot of you white broads
are thinking bill you got a lot of nerve
as a white male saying this [ __ ]
it's like well i'm just trying to get
you guys to to sit down at your seat at
the same table
there's something that's been bugging me
throughout this whole [ __ ] air quote
movement
the way [ __ ] white women have been
doing you know not all white women i
might say it all but the the [ __ ]
loudmouth ones to keep trying to if i
see one more white woman talking about
what a [ __ ] victim she is
i'm really only talking about one in
particular um
anyway um
what am i doing here
snakes in ireland
st patrick's day uh this is gonna be yet
another podcast slider i am in the
middle of uh an acting gig here
uh i will be halfway done with it later
on this week
so i don't have a lot of time to uh pay
attention to what's going on in the
world which is why
i'm bringing up people that died years
ago and saying that they're not
what other dead person are you going to
go after bill you already went after
jesus too
you called him a hippie it's not like
there was a barbershop on every corner
back then
you know i don't think he was a hippie
i don't think hippie's walking around
and let other people wash their feet
although i think that that was a of
really like
you know
i think it was a way to show respect
back in the day
i can't be i don't think there could
ever be a time that that was
you know i love all that [ __ ] though
remember that time those you know
that guy in the middle east threw his
shoes
at [ __ ] george w bush
you know and the way he ducked and got
out of the way you knew he had no
business being president
you know what i mean because he [ __ ]
ducked those things like a champ
politicians are stiff as a [ __ ] board
his [ __ ] eyes lit up like mike
singletary when he saw that guy stand up
and he [ __ ] ducked twice
you know it was funny as then they
dragged the guy out and he didn't have
his shoes either
um i want to know why that's such a
[ __ ] insult that is that is one of
them you know
there's the white glove across the face
um
different cultures
wait wait throwing shoes
side of a fence throwing
shoes
insult
all right shoe throwing or sh or shoeing
shoeing the soles of one's shoe or use
shoes to insult are forms of protest in
many parts of the world oh shoe throwing
as an insult dates back to ancient time
times being mentioned in the verse 8 of
psalm 60 and the similar verse of nine
of psalm 108 in the old testament
well can you give me a [ __ ] quote
list of shoe throwing incidents all
right here we go
i mean i got to go mike milbury mike
milbury [ __ ]
u.s president george w bush
ducking a shoe while iraq prime minister
nori
al-maki attempts to catch it
wait if he catches it does that mean
you're out
is it like dodgeball do you not get to
[ __ ] be offended again
uh
shoe throwing and shoeing
all that [ __ ] modern incidents where
shoes were thrown at political figures
have taken place in australia
oh look at that
australia looks like you have a bunch of
[ __ ] down there too
india
ireland
taiwan hong kong pakistan the united
kingdom united states and most notably
the arab world protesters of george w
bush's face
have long appeared through the middle
east with shoes attached to them
and some people have called former
senate secretary of state condoleezza
rice
uh kundera a condor i guess lisa rice
meaning shoe
shoeing received attention after uh i
can't say this
al
threw his shoes at then u.s president
george w bush
in a 14th of december 2008 press
conference in baghdad
i don't know how the [ __ ] these
politicians do that [ __ ] just be the
mouthpiece for these corporations
and then everybody [ __ ] blames you
and not the [ __ ] corporations and
you're walking around just being like
you know there's an entire country that
wants to throw their shoes at me because
of what they think i wanted to do
uh you know
well it's good to know we still arrived
how about a shout out for matunda al
zaidi
you know you got to do that i mean you
got to you mean at some point what are
you going to do you just sit there and
let these [ __ ] [ __ ] come into
your country you got to you got to say
something right i'm just trying to fill
you know by the way i'm not trying to be
anti-american here i'm just trying to
follow the narrative
that we now have now we are against
more powerful countries invading weaker
countries
so i'm just trying to i'm trying to toe
the line man you know me
government told me to wear a mask i wore
a mask and now they're telling me that i
i shouldn't be
you know supporting russia going in
a more powerful country going into uh
you know
the [ __ ] ukraine so
now now we it's just 1984 so now we
[ __ ] we we go all the way back we
change everything
am i doing it right am i doing the math
right i have [ __ ] no idea i have no
idea what's going on in the world
um
which is why i'm talking about some guy
who threw his shoes at george bush i
remember being really disappointed that
he missed him
you know what i mean i mean i always
root for the president
you know i got to tell you something
speaking of that uh i really missed
sideways at the podium donald trump
you know i really [ __ ] miss i don't
miss anything else about that guy
um
other than the bizarre
following that he has where people
actually think he's a smart guy when
it's right there
for everyone to see that the guy
couldn't even keep a [ __ ] casino
going in a casino town he takes
advantage of bankruptcy laws and [ __ ]
over the working man like [ __ ] you i'm
bigger than you sue me any chance he
gets
you know
and then how does he act
how do his followers act when they find
that out the working class people that
so love that guy they act like houston
astro feds
everybody steals sides
right
hey he [ __ ] over the working hey they
all do it
wait a minute i did that as a patriots
fan all right i'm a hypocrite um
but i don't do it part text makes me
better yeah
um
march madness has arrived ladies and
gentlemen and it's time for you
to take your hard-earned money that you
saved up to send your kid to college and
blow it on marquette
um let's see when is march madness does
marquette even in it uh march
madness
schedule
[Music]
oh my god the madness has already begun
memphis number nine memphis
we've got a sizable lead
over boise state norfolk state
getting the pounding you knew was
happening from baylor when did baylor
become a powerhouse in basketball well
they're playing norfolk state
is that like norfolk county in
massachusetts
tennessee tennessee i watched one of
their games this year had somebody on
that
team that could throw it down there's a
lot of teams this year that are in it i
never even heard of marquette is playing
they're playing unc
today at 1 30 i'm going to watch that
i'm going to watch some of the march
madness anyway you know what why don't i
just talk about the only thing that i do
have to talk about which is being um
on this acting gig and it's uh
man we did some great [ __ ] this week i'm
not even a lot of you it's been every
[ __ ] day has been
you know the actors on this thing have
been crushing it so all i'm thinking is
you know because i'm walking around the
set going like this is going to be a
[ __ ] great movie am i crazy
but all these people have been in the
business so they're going like yeah but
i see that face like you know you never
know how it comes together so that's the
only thing making me nervous
but i think uh
you know
i think we got some [ __ ] great [ __ ]
and um
i'm kind of getting excited because i've
been looking at the dailies [ __ ] that
i've been looking at the dailies i know
they look great
all right i'm not gonna lie to you guys
i don't know what the hell i'm doing but
what i'm doing i think it's looking good
um
and to update you on my food poisoning
i'm still i don't know
i'm still having uh some issues if you
know what i mean um
i don't know i i can't stay [ __ ]
hydrated i'm drinking the bubbly [ __ ]
i'm drinking the lacroix i have a
[ __ ] water every time i have any
liquid
i feel like you know i gotta stay like
you know [ __ ] bent over for half a
second like cause my stomach
deals with it
so i got so sick of eating like [ __ ]
plain white rice and crackers
and uh which by the way
if you know you can't call
the redskins the redskins anymore which
i totally understand
and can't believe it went as long as it
did
um why are we still allowed to call
crackers crackers
huh
i mean that's ridiculous
i want to know where
the progressive movement what is the
narrative on crackers
um
anyway i i
once again i just woke up this morning
and i was just like you got to be
kidding me like when is this going to be
over
all right i don't want to gross you guys
out but like i said okay i i am now a
firm believer that the human human
beings are 90 water
you know and i always wanted to you know
when people like you know
jump off something and they hit the
ground and they just [ __ ] splat
you know
you view yourself as you're like solid
you're not you're like a [ __ ] water
balloon
all right bill what else you want to
talk about i'll tell you what i want to
talk about i want to talk helicopters
and how much i miss flying him you know
i'm not allowed to fly when i'm doing
this stuff so all i've been able to do
is i just uh
you know i i run her up
you know once a week
let her go for 15 minutes you know
just so i can get the fluids going
through it's never good for an engine to
be sitting there or anything like that
and i got a buddy of mine that uh
flies it once a week
which is all it needs but uh there's
just like this time of the year is the
best [ __ ] time of the year
to fly when it's it's starting to get
hot already but when it's like still
cool out
and you get a few of those days where
it's like it was windy or something like
that the day before and it blows all the
haze out and all of that [ __ ]
um and you get up there and it just it's
just one of the most beautiful cities i
mean what the [ __ ] do i know it's the
only city i ever flew over but i'm
telling you
you have to tell you right now if you
ever want to take a [ __ ] helicopter
ride you got to do it in la if you're
into real estate i mean it's just some
it's just one
sick ass home after another right next
to another sick ass home
with no [ __ ] yard whatsoever
but there's like a big thing when you
have money that you want to have a view
you know what i mean
because not only
do you get the breathtaking view which
is amazing you also get to look down on
all of these people that you're beating
you know
i got more money than you i got more
money than you i got more money
from those [ __ ] skyscrapers all the
way out to the [ __ ] ocean
you know
and you stand out there on your astro
turf grass
right in front of your infinity pool
open robe
just surveying what you've done
[Laughter]
all right now that i've made fun of that
that would be fun to do it even if you
did it mockingly it's just fun
um
anyway
well
i will tell you this i i do know this
about food poisoning food poisoning it's
like bulimia and anorexia without the
guilt
you know because you drop the weight you
really can't eat whatever you want and
you won't put on any weight
it's just [ __ ]
[ __ ] brutal
um so
anyway i i was not gonna do [ __ ] today
uh but i do i gotta learn some [ __ ]
lines um
for saturday
which i feel is uh
i feel like i got like all like
you know when you do these things right
all the great actors i feel they just
keep reading the script and reading the
script and reading the script which is
great because you know your moments
before
and then also you can you can build an
arc for your character
you know somewhere to go with it well so
you're not like peeking too early in the
movie
um
and uh
and the other thing is is there's always
like two or three scenes be like all
right
i gotta [ __ ]
nail that
i really need to [ __ ] nail that
and then i can feel like i got
like
it's like watching a football game and
your team's up by seven you'd be like
yeah but if
what by like
we get another touchdown and a field
goal i can start feeling like we're
gonna win this game
um that's what saturday is for me
when i get past that
i've done all
you know
these bigger things
as far as like emotional [ __ ] i have to
go through and then we have
but then next week we have like a really
complex thing to shoot but that's a
that's more of a director thing but the
big acting thing is is tomorrow i'm
sorry saturday so i gotta [ __ ] get
ready to do that i gotta tell you i'm
actually having a great time
all right but i do have to do stand-up
either tonight or tomorrow because i
gotta be honest with you
i can't remember one joke in my act and
i immediately have to do a [ __ ]
you know tour
once this thing wraps but i know what
i'm gonna do i'm just gonna [ __ ]
i have like a week before i go out right
and i'm just gonna get on stage
and uh
just run it run it run it i only need to
do it three times i do it three times
i'll have the [ __ ] thing up and
running
and um
i'll get it going again i've been doing
this [ __ ] 30 years so i can get it going
but i'm very excited for that and i got
some fun gigs coming up
um i'll tell you you know if i didn't
have to take a [ __ ] [ __ ] every
[ __ ] three seconds my life is pretty
much perfect and isn't that the balance
people
that is the balance you know what i mean
if you're going to win the lottery you
know you're going to get [ __ ]
food poisoning after the crustaceans you
eat that night celebrating or something
something's going to just like
balance it
out
you know i sense
the stupid there was this
[ __ ] thing i was watching
is there anything funnier than watching
a narcissist give [ __ ]
life
advice
on [ __ ] instagram it's just [ __ ]
these [ __ ] idiots it's the only thing
funnier than that
is the comments underneath with all
these idiots are just going like truth
you know
uh you know that's how i approach it
it really is you know i should probably
look at it more empathetic where you
just sit there and you look
at how uh
i don't know
just how empty and sad you know so much
of life is as you're trying to find some
sort of meaning and purpose in it
um
beyond
how great it is on an afternoon to sit
down and have a sandwich
be able to have a sandwich and hang out
with the friend because anything beyond
that
anything [ __ ] beyond that is just
like
it's it's this right
is it wait a minute am i giving you life
advice oh [ __ ] the guy who does a
podcast with no go with no guess
um did i just say no ghosts that was
kind of weird
somebody told me a ghost story yesterday
and i was just like you know
i don't know i my thing with ghosts is i
don't [ __ ] believe in them
that has got to be the most profound
profoundly not deep thing i've ever said
in my life just the way i paused before
i said in the middle of that my whole
things with ghosts
yeah
yeah what do you think
i don't believe in them
i just don't i don't understand the
power that they have
all right you scare me and then what at
the end of the day i'm alive and you're
dead you're the one who's upset
all right
do you want to talk about it
casper whatever your [ __ ] deal is
i want to talk to people that have like
haunted houses
and i just say to them why don't you
[ __ ]
quit rolling over and showing your belly
and trying to make the spirit
you know
come to rest why don't you just [ __ ]
talk to the ghost the way you would to
any other [ __ ] that barged in when
you were sleeping
i think that's the major problem with
ghost hunters
is the level of respect that they have
for these ghosts like they achieved
something
all right they obviously did something
in their life
you know where god didn't want him and
the devil didn't want him right
i mean i just think that these are some
of the most legendary [ __ ] in the
history of of humanity
because if god doesn't want you the
devil takes you right
for the devil to also be like yeah now
nah
i don't see that vibe fitting in
down here right
in the basement apartment
so then you're just doomed to [ __ ]
walk around a town house
waiting for the sundo to go down or
hoping somebody takes a [ __ ]
afternoon nap
i don't know it's rather silly
but whenever somebody tells me a ghost
story they [ __ ] believe it
they believe it i don't know
people walking through things walking
through walls
looking at him or lifting him up in a in
a [ __ ] bed
i don't know man
i i just like
it creeps me out it's weird i got this
weird thing where i i don't watch horror
movies because i 100 take the ride they
scared the [ __ ] out of me every single
one of them
you know unless it's just an
over-the-top slasher one and then i'm
just sort of bored
but like uh
like all those saw movies
it's just so bizarre to me that people
want to go sit there and like
like you know you got all these [ __ ]
people like yeah this movie the
objectification of [ __ ] women
and all that [ __ ] like that guy you know
when he was saying he was trying to
watch that episode of ballers on my last
podcast
right
his girlfriend got all upset because she
saw it objectified women and that's why
he was watching it and stuff but like if
he put on saw
you know there's somebody chained to the
floor and what was the whole thing with
that
you got to saw your limb off
whoever saw's the limb off first gets to
get out of there or some dumb [ __ ]
um
that's got to be the number one reason
to never wear a belt
is if you're ever in a situation it's
like well you know i would saw my limb
off but i can't stop the bleeding with
the belt so
you know
if i was in that room he saw your hand
he saw your hand all right
i'd be like all right i remember biology
where's the nearest artery oh right
there
i just [ __ ] yeah just bleed out right
there
sorry buddy looks like you're gonna have
to go back to the dairy queen parking
lot and try to get another victim
because this guy just said i'm not
playing
i would love to [ __ ] reboot that
[ __ ] thing myself and just say you
know when that guy comes on the [ __ ]
drive-through speaker
and just as it's like if you want to get
out of here
you need to pick up that hacksaw
and you either saw up your foot
or you saw your hand
and i just have the person just be like
or else what
[Laughter]
what are you gonna do
what are you gonna kill me good then i
don't have to saw my [ __ ] foot off or
my hand off
i'm not gonna [ __ ]
i'm not sawing my [ __ ] foot off
and then hobbling around for the rest of
my life and what happened to your foot
oh i sawed it off
why because i was getting a soft serve
and a dairy queen
and uh somebody came up with the one
with the you know the club remember
those things from the 1990s that
they just broke your steering wheel and
took your car anyway yeah he hit me over
the head with it and then chained me to
a floor
saw your foot off go i need it
all right
this is like something on this is not
sold separately all right i either
[ __ ] leave with all of this [ __ ] or
i'm dying that's it
all right you [ __ ] weirdo what
happened to you when you were a kid huh
your dad beat you with landscaping
equipment
um sorry um all right let's get to the
uh
let's get to the um
what is it oh the the advertising here i
was trying to think of how to beat jason
jason the great thing about jason is
like he scared the [ __ ] out of you but
it was over quick
you know
and also in my heart of hearts i mean i
love anyone who's a hockey fan i'm sorry
all right zip recruit everybody
according zip
crew i can't yell my kid's sleeping
sorry according to the latest research
90 percent of employers plan to make
enhancing the employee experience
experience a top priority in 2022
after all a happy workplace is key to
attracting and keeping great employees
and if you need to add more employees to
you to your team there's zip recruiter
their matching technology helps you find
the right people for your roles fast and
right now you can try ziprecruiter for
free at ziprecruiter.com burr zip
recruiter uses its powerful technology
to find and match the right candidates
up with your job then it proactively
presents these candidates to you
uh you can easily review these
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply to your job
with
which encourages them to apply faster no
wonder zip
is the number one rated hiring site in
the u.s based on g2 rating zip
excuse me technology is so effective
that four to five employers who post on
zip recruiter get a quality usually get
a call they'll get a quality candidate
within the first day
okay so if you have some critical thing
uh position you need to fill and you
want to get the right person you go you
get off your goddamn ass
and then sit back down again especially
if you're fronting your laptop you know
and go to ziprecruiter.com try it out
for free at this exclusive website
ziprecruiter.com
it recruited dot com slash burr b-u-r-r
zip
the smartest way to hire all right
people
that is the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast
enjoy the music in a bonus episode of
the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast
and i will talk to you guys on monday
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
march
17
2014
st patrick's day falling on a monday
we're really gonna see who the [ __ ]
real drinkers are this
you know when it falls on monday either
way whatever i'm still touring canada
with the wonderful paul versi who is
once again a special guest here on the
podcast welcome paul version uh what's
up man
how you hanging in there i'm doing well
you know what do we got left how many
more days i told you i put the blinders
on didn't think about getting home you
can't and we got uh what do we got we
got tonight we got yeah dude we're three
days away from being home we got one
tonight in vancouver yeah then we're in
uh victoria then we go back to calgary
back to those animals animals [ __ ]
animals in calgary jesus not the first
show the second show wow
oh my god i'm trying to say we wanted to
reach out to people in calgary before we
we just brand everybody
in calgary animals like they they were
[ __ ] pounding you know what that
first show was great they yeah they were
great that second show though whoa
yeah
yeah dude they were like uh they were
coming in with cases of tall boys they
were allowed to bring those little those
little cardboard pallets hammered
hammered [ __ ] hammers and then then
they had like uh
you know one i think part of it had to
do with the fact that it was at a
college so i think there was college
kids there i just put myself in that
mindset going dude i drank like that
when i was in college this isn't how i
don't know though dude that wasn't all
college people because i asked the crowd
and like that that was just i think that
was a lot of just calgary man i think
that was late night
you know
i think what was permitted on the
premises turned them into [ __ ]
animals
yeah you know they you know by the time
i went on stage when i got halfway
through my set it was most of them had
kind of like passed out like it got was
getting quiet and i was standing up
there
going like am i bombing up here and i
just was looking at like five different
people who were laughing their ass off
and i'm like
i'm just gonna say in my head they're
sober
yeah like there's no way if i'm really
bombing i got somebody laughing that
hard so i was just like maybe this show
has gone on too long like i'll tell you
that was a rough one you know it was
animals in calgary what was i at the zoo
okay
still fun so then we we're driving out
me and verzi we're trying to find a
place to smoke a stogy inside
right or they had this that john
on that campus which was really exciting
to me was they had the speed skating
loop from the 1988 olympics and they
still had ice on it we were trying to
get on that [ __ ] oh dude that would
have been a great youtube video if they
loaned us some speed skates
going out there and have stand-up comedy
clothes with those giant blades on it i
just want to be going fast enough i want
to be going fast enough where i'm turned
so to the side i can put those three
fingers down you know when you go around
the corner oh my god yeah no i would
never i would have been on youtube for
the wrong reasons oh yeah both of us
would have wiped out and i would you
know when they wipe out when the
centrifugal force just takes you into
the stands
yeah that would have been me
that would have been me so anyways we're
trying to do that uh we ended up finding
this great place to smoke a cigar so
we're driving out
and we're trying to figure out going to
was
you know we're talking about the show
going like it was it me or that the
first show was good but that second show
wow
um did you feel the same way and we know
basically exchanging notes and as we
drive out of the venue
uh we see this group of [ __ ] hammered
people and this guy he's got you know
what those things like when they have a
parade go down the street those giant
like metal
um
the barricades yeah those metal ones
that have like it looks like a [ __ ] i
don't know whatever giant metal
barricade this [ __ ] guy picks it up
with one hand and he's got it over his
shoulder turns around sees us coming and
then waves us through like he's some
sort of official per for half a second
the way he did it i thought he was
and then as i drove by
i'm looking at him and i see he's sam
he's hammered and then i see on his face
it registers that with the two comics he
just saw
so
um i just pull away from him and as i'm
driving and you're going like wow man
that guy just had was carrying that
thing with one hand what the [ __ ] i turn
around look in the rearview mirror and
this guy's running after the the car
we're doing probably like what 15 miles
an hour yeah and this dude is running i
was saying he looked like you know when
they show highlights of babe ruth
hitting a home run when they show him
running and fast fast legs yeah he was i
think he was mocking running i don't
think he was really going to do anything
because i didn't get scared but when i
looked in the rearview mirror and i just
saw this guy just imagine
you're driving along after a [ __ ]
working or whatever you're kind of
halfway out of it and then you look in
the rearview mirror and you see somebody
running but in this exaggerated way
where he was like pumping his [ __ ]
arms like that it was like he was
mocking it i didn't see it all i saw was
you go what the you go what the [ __ ] and
you just stepped on the gas but i was in
the past
underpowered [ __ ] rental car so
and all of a sudden you go what the [ __ ]
and i go what and you just stepped i
guess you go that guy just started
running after the car and i was like
holy [ __ ] because i saw one of his
friends right one of those just
collapsed
like they were so hammered that he
didn't hit anything he just fell a guy
just fell and i just saw his legs go up
like
they were [ __ ] up dude those kids i
would be lying if like like three times
yesterday and this morning i woke up and
i was picturing that guy running behind
the car and i laughed every time it was
[ __ ] nuts yeah those guys were
hammered man yeah so we got a tip tip of
the cap to uh the drinking ability yeah
not encouraging that from when we come
back wednesday we definitely like to
have people try to behave more like the
first show where uh
you know i don't feel like i'm
interrupting your drinking with my with
my jokes
yeah yeah that was the they were great
though the crowds were great yeah yeah
they were great but yeah man that was
that was another level yeah there was
there's always a couple there's always a
couple hammered people but that was
where it was getting to the tipping
point like kind of like you know right
before hitler took power where it's just
like what side am i going to choose here
yeah for my own survival is that's what
the drunk versus sober level was by the
time i got about 40 minutes into my set
it was kind of like that's the thing
you're doing you're doing an hour plus
i'm going out there up front you know i
could kind of see that they're animals
but you know i could just you going out
there by the time you're halfway through
your set these guys are like six tall
boys in it's a [ __ ] show it's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] show it was a [ __ ] show edmonton
edmonton was unbelievable edmonton at
that venue you remember that one with
the the orchestra [ __ ] place there oh
yeah that was great so then we have a
great time there and then the uh
we ended up uh
where the [ __ ] did we go i remember we
kept leaving the hotel
we kept we drove around about yeah you
had to get socks versions [ __ ]
hilarious bersie has not done
laundry i bought new [ __ ] you know
dude we're like 20 what what 17 we were
16 days in yeah you got 16 days worth of
[ __ ] socks and drawers yeah i got
them in a plastic bag and then i went to
the store and i bought new ones you know
it would have cost me the same [ __ ]
thing get we got to take a picture of
your bag at some point post it how big
is it getting yeah you have he has him
on the outside pouch well you're
checking the bag
so i guess it doesn't matter
but uh i just did mine for the second
time i i that i [ __ ] hate having
dirty
you go back past a certain amount of
days like i'm doing three four days in a
row plastic bags stuff them in the front
or whatever but you do laundry at home
is it do you do it or does your wife do
it
uh my wife does it yeah yeah me too hey
i got her in line you know okay
so anyways last week uh oh wait i gotta
finish the edmond thing edmonton thing
so verzi is completely addicted to
skating now and he wants to get better
at it
and um
so we're [ __ ] in uh edmonton the next
morning we gotta drive down to calgary
and percy's going like there's got to be
a place here to skate so we find out
they have
uh they have a skating rink at the mall
and not only is it a mall it's one of
the most giant malls
in north america america yeah west
edmonton rivaling uh what's that one in
minnesota mall of america mall of
america yeah yeah yeah so
which i've been to that one too so we go
to that one we're walking through there
with our [ __ ] skates two middle-aged
guys walking through this thing with
[ __ ] skates
and uh we walk in there's like this
giant pirate ship
i mean like yeah you could sail the
[ __ ] ocean with this [ __ ] thing
yeah it was a [ __ ] official and i
looked on the other side it was really
deep water and it took all this time to
make it look like there was a shipwreck
jesus christ i mean like you could
[ __ ]
you know it was monstrous man like shaq
could drown in this water if he didn't
that's how [ __ ] deep it was huge and
then we look on the other side and i'm
like paul i'm like is that a [ __ ] sea
lion
they had sea lions at this thing they're
like throwing it fishing fishing it was
catching a trainer was don't it wasn't
like people just walking by throwing
[ __ ] from the food court it was a
trainer throwing it and um
so we're just walking through the mall
walking through the mall endless [ __ ]
well they had a water park there yeah it
was i didn't look at any stores i was
too distracted by the [ __ ] in the middle
and then we finally get all the way to
the ice palace they called it ice palace
and we got all excited and we're the
only people with skates just walking
through holding our [ __ ] dumb skates
and we get all the way to the other side
versus all excited like dude i'm telling
you i'm gonna get better at this you
wait i was getting i was ready this
summer he's already talking [ __ ] dude
calling it right now i'm gonna be
[ __ ] skating backwards you're gonna
be like what the [ __ ] happened versi
yeah right and then we show up
and uh there's a big judo tournament
where the ice rink is and they'd [ __ ]
put all this floor flooring all over it
i was in denial i'm like maybe this
isn't the rink
dude it says ice palace paul this is it
they covered it up this is it i got
upset though at the mall man remember
remember that girl man that really
bothered me we're walking through the
food court and you know i we had a gyro
great gyro
yeah yeah a great gyro this place called
jimmy the greek the one complaint and
you agreed a little too much white sauce
and it was pasty yeah it wasn't it
wasn't yeah it was a little pasty
scoop he went to one one scoop less than
a little hot sauce
excited he got excited it would have
been epic yeah we got excited so then i
said to bill you know i like a little
dessert after i eat you know i like a
little candy bar i like a little you
know like a little sugar
[Laughter]
so i go bill man there was a frozen
yogurt place i go yeah pink berry or
something so go let's go frozen yogurts
you all right so we're walking let's
paint the picture so two middle-aged men
with skates i know i don't like how you
keep saying i'm middle-aged you are
middle-aged i'm 30 i just turned 35 35
times two
70.
most guys [ __ ] drop
well i call i call like i call middle
yeah all right what would you call it no
i guess you're right i guess you know i
always just when i thought of it as a
kid i always felt you know it was
no i don't know i i just remember dude i
it's i don't know won't you say 40
40s but i you know 40s 40 people dude
people live long man
dude i'm [ __ ] be 46 46 times two is
ninety two you're going to really i
can't really sit there and say i'm
middle-aged
tell you the way i'm eating and smoking
you know
[Laughter]
no so so we walked through and we're
like where's that where was that uh
frozen yogurt place let's go to that
frozen yogurt place so we too we see two
young women walk by and we figure hey i
looked at them and i'm like these these
these ladies they're gonna know where
they're gonna know where the pink fairy
is so we walk up and you go first you
say to the friend you go hey you got you
guys know where oh good they're good
looking too by the way yeah good good
looking girls and you go up first you go
hey you guys know where the frozen
yogurt place is and like she did like a
double take like she did a double take
so [ __ ] rude right and she just was
like what and then i looked at the other
one and i go yeah like a pinkberry and
she kind of just like gives a shake off
like how would i know like why you and
she [ __ ] did this is what she did she
did the classic pretty girl you're
clearly just asking me this because you
want to talk to me thing and i'm like no
[ __ ] i want some [ __ ] yogurt okay i
want [ __ ] i want a [ __ ] treat you
know i just had lunch and and it really
bothered me dude and we were walking
around and i wanted to find her i wanted
to walk past this again they did the
loop on the floor i didn't know that but
i said to bill when we got to the car i
wanted to find her because i would have
just went up to her and go you know
something i found it you're a mean jerk
and then you go why would you do that
you're a mean jerk that's terrible what
am i gonna call her a [ __ ]
well don't call her anything if you're
gonna go with mean jerk i mean you know
i hate that you're a girl mentality that
pretty good say you're mean or you're a
jerk if you want to stay clean but if
you go you're a mean jerk no you're not
you're not you're not pretty inside
you're not pretty insane she doesn't
give a [ __ ] she's the hot girl at the
mall paul put yourself in her [ __ ]
pumps all right
we're too [ __ ] [ __ ] her jackass is
standing there with ice skates when
there's a judo tournament down the way
asking if they know where the [ __ ]
the ice cream store is
they looked at us the way they were
supposed to i you know what dude i like
a sweetheart i don't care how you i
would love to hear them tell the story
and they come and then this just creepy
guy comes up like
you know where they are
that's the way they're going to hear it
paul paul you ever watch those [ __ ]
prison shows
which ones like the scared straight no
not those ones where they they talk
about the worst prisons in the country
and that type of [ __ ] oh yeah i've seen
a couple yeah and you just sit there
watching it going how the [ __ ]
would i go in there and not get raped
what would my game plan you get scared
watching it in your bedroom right women
have to
walk out of the house worried about that
that somebody's gonna you know dude just
imagine if if uh dude i had a winter hat
on with a puffy ball on top of it
holding ice skates asking for yogurt
yeah if anything she probably thought i
was [ __ ] gay
you don't look gay paul i know but
you're not you're not questioning you're
not your beard's too terroristic you're
you need to get a little more
metrosexual i'm going to do that we was
we had sweatpants on dude we were a mess
everybody in the [ __ ] ground yeah
that's what you look my my beard
actually [ __ ] says everybody on the
[ __ ] ground no but dude i i don't
like the pretty girl who can't be
approached with a question because oh
this guy's hitting on me it's it's awful
and you know something the guy
especially the blonde one who went like
shook her head like what she's gonna be
a nightmare she's a [ __ ] nightmare
for some future guy i'm telling you
she's a nightmare she's already selfish
it's over
what if she just knows what she wants
and we're not it
paul this is the thing dude you actually
allowed like how old do you think they
were
they were probably 21 22. yeah you let
21 22 year old
i mean that's a girl at my age not even
a woman the way she should get it you
let it ruin like dude we're driving down
to calgary yeah she ruined the rocky
mountains on the right-hand side of the
car and you're just still calling you're
calling her a [ __ ] the whole way down
it bothered the [ __ ] out of me it was
like why you why would you ask me how
would i know
dude you realize how funny that is that
they did that to us
like what like yeah they really made us
feel like [ __ ] that's [ __ ] hilarious
if you look at it it bothered and the
whole time it is because you wanted to
get frozen yogurt dude how funny would
it be if we chased him down
you got frozen yogurt with sugar-free
gummy bears on it it was all natural no
organic gummy bears how great would it
be if we chased him down and i just
walked up to her and i go you know
something
you hurt my feelings
i just [ __ ] broke down
you know you hurt my feelings i just
wanted yogurt
by the way for people listening here
this is last week you know you know just
trying to kill just trying to make jokes
to not go out of your mind being on tour
this [ __ ] long yeah is we were doing
the danger field everything i'll tell
you a good friend of mine i love yogurt
you know
so we were doing that
and once that went away that got old
somewhere along the line you started
doing it
you started saying really sentimental
[ __ ] to me and then pretending like you
were crying and then that just became
like the running joke and then you
started laughing and then you were just
like you got to do that on stage do that
crying thing so now we'll just go up and
like if we'll be like hey man i'm tired
but dude you know what hang on hanging
with you on the road has been great
you're the only one i could have done it
with
and then bill would come and tag it
that's the best thing bill would come
and tag and i would just be like i was
hoping you were going to say that
it's been it's been [ __ ] wonderful
for my anger i'm gonna try to do that
when i get home just pretend like i'm
crying man it's [ __ ] hilarious so two
stories we go in to eat and we have this
filipino waiter right by the way i like
to play the games where i see where the
hell were we was that edmonton was that
calgary that was edmonton yeah it was
edmonton so i like to do this thing
where sometimes i like to [ __ ] with
people so i'll just get on a phone and
i'll be like bill go along with it and
we'll be in an elevator and i'll go what
no that's horse [ __ ] and like bill just
pick what happened so like i said like
he had a parole officer called
and he said and bill goes oh they worked
it up and then instantly burr goes yeah
but what about that videotape i go no no
they said it's insubmissible
and like and like the guy there's just a
stranger there right sometimes i break
out laughing so
bill calls it he gets a little emotional
guy so we we turn this crying thing we
do it like this has been great
right we
turned that into doing it in public so
we have this filipino waiter right and
the whole guy was great he was talking
to us and at the end i just go
he goes uh here's your bill and i go i
just want to say something
and i kept the dead straight face like
you've been a great waiter man
and i put my hand on his [ __ ] arm and
i go do you know what you bring in the
waters he just
and bill just looks at him goes he gets
a little he gets a little emotional you
know i mean no but it's been it means a
lot i didn't know what to do guy had no
because he was so [ __ ] polite and he
was actually from the philippines
so
dude you jumped right in perfectly my
friend he gets a little emotional like
no but billy he'd bring the waters oh
dude he was freaked out though no that's
the new game on the road but you had the
best one i gotta say the best one was at
the airport yesterday we go to the
airport yesterday and bill starts
busting my balls about my laundry and he
goes versey [ __ ] 16 days and you're
carrying you know dirty socks and
underwear and i go dude i go i bought
new ones you know the dirty ones are
tied up tight in a in a plastic bag and
bill just goes just like your emotions
and dude i [ __ ] could not walk
i couldn't walk and i had to stop
pulling my [ __ ] my the bag i checked
because we were laughing so hard and it
works though makes it makes it [ __ ]
great it's driving our tour manager nuts
oh yeah that's the one thing yeah well
because women don't want to see a guy
getting emotional like that it's just
well no because once somebody cries it's
over yeah like when i go out afterwards
and i'm taking pictures with people and
stuff i always come back i was just
saying i got to tell you
i've seen a lot of people do that you
know doing the picture thing but you got
to be one of the best
it's just lives she's going would you
stop [ __ ] doing that our wives are
going to go nuts
because you know the first thing i want
i see stays and you see your wife we're
just gonna go it's been so long i missed
you so much no you got you got to set it
up with talking like you got to start
off normal
you're going to say something really
sentimental to him so they're almost
crying and then you cry which ruins
their cry and i swear to god you get
slugged in the shoulder which is all you
really want
um how many minutes in here i think it's
time to do a little advertising here you
know okay what have we got
did i just shut it off no i didn't oh
[ __ ] 20 minutes in i'll tell you paul
you know time really flies with you on
the podcast
it's been so fun
this is probably only funny to us but i
don't give a [ __ ] try it with your
friends oh [ __ ] that the game the game
is called he gets emotional and just
walk into a bar
just have one of your friends start
hitting on a woman and then and then the
other friends got to go along yeah and
then just starts welling up and then the
other guy goes i'm sorry he just gets
emotional and you just got to let the
other person deal with it dude you're
one at the [ __ ] airport where you
walked up to that lady at the car the
little [ __ ] i sell gum whatever the
hell it is
he said excuse me do you have the uh you
have the one of the biggest night i
broke out i go hey hey man you do what
are the biggest condoms you got yeah
what's the biggest size condoms you have
i turned around and walked away and you
turned around and walked away and i'm
just staring at her and i'm biting my
tongue as hard as i can to not laugh and
then i just burst out laughing she said
what and then when you went to repeat it
you started to try to point to it and i
lost it you lost it and had to walk away
paul we're punch drunk out here all
right i got to do a little um
got to do some advertising here okay
hulu plus
everybody uh you've probably tried
hulu.com this is new this is hulu plus
you can watch your favorite shows
anytime anywhere with hulu plus
they told me to stress plus this week
hulu plus lets you watch thousands of
hit tv shows in a selection of acclaimed
movies on your television or on the go
with your smartphone or tablet and it
all streams in hd for the best viewing
experience possible this is incredible
paul you can watch stuff right on your
phone in hd quality with hulu
plus
i like this you can watch your favorite
current tv shows like saturday night
live community and family guy you can
also check out exclusive content
including hulu originals like the
authens starring snl seth meyers and
moonboy starring chris o'dowd from
bridesmaid
with hulu plus
uh also offers a great selection of
acclaimed films for only 7.99 a month
you can stream as many tv shows and
movies as you want wherever you want how
do you get it right now you can try hulu
plus free for just two weeks when you go
to huluplus.com bill this is a special
offer for just my listeners make sure
you go to huluplus.com bill so you get
the extended free trial and that they
know i sent you go to hulu plus slash
bill now or click on the hulu plus
banner on the podcast page at
billbird.com i would like a morning
radio show here all right
dollar shave club everybody okay guys
you've heard me talk about how much i
love love
dollarshaveclub.com so why haven't you
joined
it makes your life so much better like
you don't have anything better to do
than go to the store or anything better
to spend your money on than raises
what's wrong with you in the last two
years
dollarshaveclub.com has served have
saved hundreds of thousands of dollars
uh what hundred thousand of guys time by
delivering amazing razors and high
quality grooming products right to their
door go to dollarshaveclub.com forward
slash burr shave with their razors i'm a
forex guy but my buddy swears by his
executive
is that my
split personality talking there um and
check out dr cabazeezy shave butter
seriously this stuff is amazing it makes
shaving feel like you're softly wiping
whiskers off your face oh what a visual
that is tremendous writing there and you
can't forget about one white charlie's
the butt wipes for men that's right a
butt wipe for men peppermint tingle
enough said try it out your sphincter
will love you is that the right word for
your [ __ ] uh what are you waiting for
you can get deliveries every other month
if you need and you can cancel any time
if you don't like it dollarshaveclub.com
wants you to be uh i want you to be
great and keep extra cash in your pocket
uh i'm a member of dollarshaveclub.com
now it's your turn dude we've already
made the point why are we still going
here save time shave money join
dollarshaveclub.com go to
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash burr
to let them know that i sent you that's
dollarshaveclub.com
forward slash burr
oh jesus what do we got left here i'll
save i'll save those one more here paul
what do you think back to the podcast
back in the podcast there we go all
right
all right i'll tell you what happened
and join up here oh let me tell you
dude they show [ __ ] uh
hockey highlights you can't believe i'm
not watching any games because i'm
traveling and i'm totally staying up on
it like you know like that uh sunday
night when they show all the football
highlights
it's incredible everywhere we've gone
down to sit there's been a tv within our
right there playing staying right up on
it i'm watching the bruins win i'm
watching tyler sagan having a great year
but they got smoked by the sabers i
watched the flyers highlights have a big
win over over uh
the penguins i know vancouver just beat
luango down in florida i know that
[ __ ] old uh
uh flashy toast there is back between
the pipes in montreal
price yeah hey look at me vanit got his
first goal as a canadian i'm sitting
there watching this paul as i'm having a
beer with you and an irish coffee and a
pub around the corner oh and my
listeners know that i never drink on pet
st patrick's day it's [ __ ] amateur
night to use jackie gleason's famous
phrase not if you do it early enough
though i think it's amateur hour tonight
listen not if but we'll be there not if
you're in your hotel and all of a sudden
they say there's a gas leak and you can
[ __ ] smell it oh how about that you
have to run down the stairs then what
are you supposed to do how about you
left half your [ __ ] in the room and you
walk up the street and there's a guy
with bagpipes playing the green
alligator long neck goose you're not
gonna go in there
you know i'm glad you were had to look
at the band i'm glad that you're you're
my vantage point with my back to them
and you had to look because when she
went into that like irish hip-hop beat
and i just turned for a second saw her
like jumping up and down i just i
probably would have lost oh yeah
i love what you said where you go dude i
hope this is good because if it's not
i'm just gonna have to stare at my beard
yeah because she she introduced it and
it was good i just did a brutal version
of it but it was more sane no it was
okay they were actually very different i
was saying this is like scottish
uh beat boxing and i just looked at paul
and i go paul she's about to do scottish
beatboxing from the old country and i go
this is either going to be amazing or
i'm gonna have to sit here staring at my
beer
uh vancouver's awesome praying for it to
be over well let's go to the gas leak so
we're sitting here in the hotel oh yeah
and um you know
i know verzi is not a morning person i
have not called you one i haven't woken
you up other than before going to the
airport just to make sure you're coming
so if we have a day off i don't [ __ ]
with you i i let you wake up yeah yes
it's a great it's great i don't poke the
bear so
i know that we're going to do the
podcast we're going to try to do it
around
12 noon here
and uh
because i'm trying to sleep off this
little cold that i've caught
but um
all of a sudden you you call me i'm like
oh great version's up and then you're
like dude
hey what's going on there's a gas leak
in the building they told us to get out
of here and i'm just sitting there like
no i was walking out to go get lunch and
all of a sudden i see a construction
worker come in full thing he just runs
in he goes hey yeah we're running we got
running like it scared me as i'm walking
out he just goes hey we got a guest and
i just smell and there's a hundred
construction workers outside and just
warning people to run down the street it
was like a [ __ ] scene so i'm going oh
[ __ ] bill's up there so let me call bill
cause it's a friend i am
it's the [ __ ] that you thought about me
so so i call bill and i go dude you
gotta i go there's a gas leak and it
smells you gotta they're gonna probably
evacuate you go you cut me off you heard
gas leak and they're probably gonna
evacuate you go dude i'm on my way down
yeah you just got the [ __ ] you got the
[ __ ] out of it i don't mind getting
blown up i'm worried about burning to
death so i had to get the [ __ ] out of
this so i'm grabbing everything and i'm
sitting i got to get out i got to get
out of here and i grab my watch i'm like
that's going to be the move right there
that [ __ ] kills me so i go outside
you know try to find the exit and i'm
running down the thing and when i got to
the the right to right where i go i'm on
the fifth floor okay these these
construction guys were working on some
sort of line in the street and somebody
[ __ ] up they hit something yeah
so i got right to the fire escape doors
dude and it smelled like when you go to
light a grill
and you think you have uh some juice
left in your automatic lighter and there
isn't and you just take that extra three
seconds to find some matches and then
you light it and it goes
you know yeah whoa what the [ __ ] that's
what it smelled like a little more
intense and i'm thinking i'm on the
fifth floor of this [ __ ] place yeah
so i ran down those stairs
um
and went out the side and then i got out
the side of the building thinking okay
i'm safe and i still smelled it almost
worse
and i was standing right outside the
hotel yeah trying to find you and i
could still smell it i'm like if this
whole [ __ ] thing's going up i'm going
to get knocked on my ass here because it
at the
least because i can still smell this
[ __ ] i got a hat on with the pom-pom
paul i'm gonna go up like a [ __ ]
bowling alley so then they finally they
told all of us to get the hell out of
the way and we backed up we went down
the street we got some breakfast and i
thought it was a really nice moment
it's never not funny
anyways the nice thing is you got you
got the out here you wouldn't have you
wouldn't have burned
right with the balcony because i got
about well i have a balcony on on the
fifth floor and then there's like a
patio right on the other side of it i
don't know paul when you're on fire i
don't want to i don't mind blowing up i
just don't want to burn to death
that's [ __ ] awful yeah if there's an
explosion i want to die i don't want to
be coming out you know running down the
street like that naked girl in the
vietnam picture that girl like she got
burned by [ __ ] agent orange that's
what she's running down the street
because skin is hanging off her [ __ ]
backside
horrible uh [ __ ] horrible paul yeah
but this how great is vancouver
yeah now that we got the image of a
naked girl running down the street on
fire uh yes
that's all but that's what i was
thinking of
yeah sorry that image touched me when i
saw it
nobody should die like that
i swear to god i hope they're finding
this funny this is gonna be the most
annoying podcast ever
whatever [ __ ] you you go to canada for
20 days dancing like a monkey you have
to come up with some [ __ ] too
we get emotional yeah um vancouver yeah
vancouver's great love it i loved
edmonton calgary unfortunately i didn't
get a chance like that's that street uh
right outside our hotel man and all
these bars and all these great places to
eat really really [ __ ] fun towns yeah
and um when i was in winnipeg oh
winnipeg was rough you know no let me
tell you those people are tough okay
well i saw a guy the other day i don't
know how to finish it but no dude
winnipeg was like you know me i don't
like to fly when i after winnipeg i was
like let's go to the airport like and
and the people were great and the food
was great there's no way you like
that part of the world to live there in
the wintertime
it's you have to be a special kind of
tough or you're you're out the second
you turn 18 like [ __ ] you parents you're
out yeah no the people were great the
food was great we had great it was
outstanding was that that tortilla i had
which is a french canadian like a meat
pie yeah flaky crust they had the crust
underneath they didn't they didn't skimp
on that sometimes you ordered a shepherd
pie or a meat pie and they just you know
they [ __ ] cook up the meat stick it
in a bowl and they put just the dough on
the top yeah i want this thing you know
i want i want both parents to be there
right the one on top and on the bottom
right just nestling that you gave me a
piece of it it was unreal and i dude i
had chicken salad to make you cry you
know it was great we had great food over
there did you get emotional paul
i've tasted a lot of things but that was
no uh i yeah when but my you know i i
love the room last night i love that
like it's like kind of like a beacon
theater right up front that's what i
loved edmonton was like long edmonton
room almost was like carnegie was just
deep and layers i was on that night dude
i went out there and the [ __ ] add was
working to my sometimes it [ __ ] me up
it was working great oh dude edmonton
[ __ ] just shuffled the deck of all my
jokes and then that made me say other
[ __ ] now it's just like one of those
things where i felt like i was on stage
for five minutes on that one no dude you
edmonton was ugh that was [ __ ]
edmonton actually i had a showstopper
where like
i don't even want to be in vaudeville i
had a [ __ ] this guy's a showstopper
no i had a real triple threat
no i had a bad show stopper i'm i'm
saying that in a bad way you [ __ ] oh
that was my fault i shouldn't no i i did
that i did that joke where i was just
like you know women you know you guys
like get personal trainers
and you you know you go all out for your
wedding picture and your wedding day and
you look great you look like an olympian
and then i go
and then it just kind of falls apart but
like and the place just [ __ ] stopped
yeah someone in the crowd went wow well
somebody else no somebody goes oh my god
yeah and like i had a the bid i did
before it killed and then i did that and
i go no no and i kind of saved it when i
go no what i'm saying is like you should
just come down the aisle the way you're
gonna be
like what i'm gonna be looking at for
the next 40 or 50 years and like half of
them laughed but i was just like
somebody was like well then i told you
afterwards and the look on your face you
were just like wow
yeah [ __ ] but i was the idiot you said
it to me in the restaurant it was fun it
was funny to me
so i said dude you got to do that on
stage
and then somehow the way you said that
you said it i was just like i mean
that's [ __ ] i mean that though dude i
mean you can't women have to
they have to give birth
can you imagine that no doesn't matter
what the [ __ ] you do you stay in shape
you do all that and then if you're going
to have another kid you're basically
going to have to go through that and
what they're they're ain't no what i'm
saying how could you no what i'm saying
is and this is what i'm saying you know
i know women dude and you know my wife
it looks great she had two kids and
everything and i know women go through a
lot of [ __ ] and have kids i'm saying
don't put on that show for everybody
else be who the [ __ ] you're gonna be
it's the same way people you know clean
up for company like what the regular
family is not good you know and just
being aunt betty who we don't see ever
who's coming over once a [ __ ] year is
what you got to get on the your hands
and knees with a toothpick or two you
know what it's i i'll go with this it
does suck
when it's somebody that you don't give a
[ __ ] about and your wife saying we gotta
clean this [ __ ] place up yeah and
they're going all it isn't just like
okay let me let's just pick a room that
we throw all the [ __ ] in and close the
door like you they actually want you to
clean up that they're coming in from
maryland i don't give a [ __ ] not gonna
see him again
right you know
right but as far as i'm looking good on
the wendy i want to i want him to look
as good as i can i would like i know i
was trying to do i was joking at [ __ ]
backfire well i i i wasn't there for you
as a friend you know and i'll tell you
that's going to haunt me forever
[Laughter]
um
yeah but what what was the name of the
theater that we played in winnipeg man
uh burton cummings yeah that play it was
it was an it was uh i got a little some
of the history of that that place was
made in uh 1908.
yeah and uh they had these these [ __ ]
stairs in the back now everybody charlie
chaplin
uh uh uh who's the guy there
uh
fatty arbuckle
harry houdini all these it was a
vaudeville theater for like the first 30
years before the talkies took over see
and um
they still had like the original stairs
in the back yeah you walked up to the
green room and these are like slabs i
don't know what kind of stone it is but
from years of people walking up in it
where you basically you put your feet
there was like these indentations from
people scuffing up as they were walking
up or coming how did it go
yeah and then outside
uh the upper deck of it
the i guess the mezzanine in the upper
deck they used to have pews all the way
through them and then they put seats in
at some point but in the upper deck they
still had
these wooden pews and during my set
because the acoustics are incredible
he's talking 1908 i mean i don't think
they could really amplify voice at that
point could they i don't know yeah we
don't know we're idiots but i don't
think they could so it's it's was
acoustically perfect building so when
people were way up in that upper deck
we're talking like an old hockey barn
for hockey fans there were basketball
fans where you felt like if you lean too
far forward you'd fall right on the
emblem at center ice or center court and
these people would walk down it's making
that that sound like you almost like an
old chair makes all that rickety [ __ ]
and it sounded like it was right above
me and i was sitting there going are
these [ __ ] union guys walking around
making noise during my show and i kept
making jokes like that that they were
already changing the marquee and they
were over me and what it was
was people
in that upper deck were walking down
just to go to the bathroom and get a
drink but the acoustics were so
unbelievable and it was so [ __ ] steep
it was sound it sounded like it was
right above my head yeah it was amazing
that was one of my uh that place was old
school yeah i like old [ __ ] dude so i i
actually walked up there
at the end of my show
i wish you did it dude it was it
reminded me uh there's one in uh in
seattle that we did the the more theater
yeah where uh i think they shot the uh
the video for even flow
when i hold it
yeah yeah
that one right when he's [ __ ] hanging
and he's looking like he's bleary-eyed
you know yeah like he's crazy but he
isn't he knows exactly what he's doing
he already knows he wants to fire his
drummer
um
we played that one and that one was
really interesting where just like this
one that we played in winnipeg they have
separate entrances for the upper deck
and that i don't know if they had
segregation up here but in seattle that
was what that was for
that upper deck you had a completely
separate entrance
no [ __ ] elevator and you just walked
up flight after flight after flight and
these were serious flights like 14
groupings
you know two groups of like 14 to get to
one floor all the way all the way all
the way up and i was joking with the guy
going this is why african americans
kicked the [ __ ] out of white people
because
in sports because we just strolled into
the theater hell yes and just have a
seat they got to do like the [ __ ]
stair master yeah all the way up and
come back down just to see a [ __ ]
show and that's like insanely high man
like that was scary high yeah like when
you say steep it's like you don't want
to lean forward like steep like you're
[ __ ] it was scary yeah like i would
not want to be
like hammered oh no up there up there
and then you know smoke a little joint
or something somewhere smoke a cigar
that made me [ __ ] lightheaded i would
just be like
i mean if i had to leave i would i would
go hands and knees backwards
down like a little you know a little
toddler goes downstairs
that's how i would exit
with the uh with the fear you like the
burton cummings one i like i think um
i think the vogue last night was one of
my favorites man
oh dude those are two great crowds too
yeah yeah and we're not [ __ ] on
calgary by the way it was just that
second show dude it's been a while
since i've been in front of people that
drunk but uh we had another amazing week
now when did we play hockey oh wait we
went to the bruins canadians game yeah
yeah what is the name of that place
molson center yeah they changed it they
changed it whatever the [ __ ] it is now
you know i don't know some sort of
cellular company
but uh it's just uh an amazing place to
go to where you see all those retired
numbers all those bad stanley cup
banners and just how into it people are
there were some people leaving early
down below that kind of disappointed me
well i mean but it was a beat down
it was a beat down you know bruins
[ __ ] killed down three goals in the
third period hey and i wasn't obnoxious
either i i didn't like the guy who
brought me to it he was a canadians fan
he said hey we're going to go into this
this you know the famous i don't know
one of the levels there the mezzanine
level they have this pub
and
the guy who hooked us up with the ticket
said listen i know he's a big bruins fan
but i don't respect kids you just not
wear stuff it gets weird when you go in
there i was just like yeah absolutely
i'm not gonna [ __ ] do that yeah you
know i'm gonna stand up and share when
we score but i'm not gonna be that
[ __ ] going yeah yeah in the face you
know giving them [ __ ] or whatever i'm
not gonna do that no no yeah yeah so i
just sat there and i thoroughly [ __ ]
enjoyed it
and uh but earlier that day
we actually uh some of the guys from
just for laughs bruce hill hooked us up
with some ice time and i got the [ __ ]
kicked out of me yeah and versi played
hockey for the first time we played at
this this you know they got a zillion
rinks out there and it was uh old
canadian
uh stefan
uh yeah he played you know back when i
was first going to games and [ __ ] like
that or maybe five years into when i
started going to games and uh he somehow
i forget how it was but his jersey was
framed there so anyways we played on
this little sort of mini rink
we had the floating blue line you bring
it to the zone then the red line becomes
the blue line and i gotta tell you versi
[ __ ] animal he's out there with just
gloves a stick and a helmet dude you had
like three shots on that
on like i mean i don't know if you try
like trying to tap rebounds in his shots
on that i don't know how that [ __ ]
works but dude you had like three and
one shift and i was sitting there
laughing on the bench go this [ __ ]
guy's got more shots on net in one shift
well one of the guys i was like dude i
said like we were talking like maybe
throughout the whole game i might have
had like 12 shots but i didn't know how
to stop i got the [ __ ] kicked out of me
i'm falling down and everyone's got pads
but me so i'm the most novice in this
thing all right and the only thing i had
was gloves and a helmet i'm falling on
my knees and elbow getting and like it
was so legit that there were two locker
rooms you had your own jerseys there was
a timer these guys had shifts and i'm
getting thrown into this thing okay i
haven't been on the ice you know why
i've been dragging all my stuff up here
because yeah we're gonna play i want to
make sure i'm protected and i'm not
going to wear somebody else's smelly
stuff that's [ __ ]
that's gross dude that's like the pad
version of using your buddy's toothbrush
it's gross
but yeah and typical me i'm like i don't
know how to play but i just know scoring
position from floor hockey so i just
would go down get into scoring position
not know how to stop and just [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] kicked out of me i would
i'll tell you this
one thing a coach would never have to
tell you is go to the net that's all you
did the second your team
the second your team got the puck i just
went you didn't understand offsides
though you were offsides a couple of
times what the [ __ ] dude you would just
put your head down
and just
just start skating and you had your
stick on the ice the wrong way because
every time i shot i wouldn't need a
lefty stick so i had the righty stick
which had it opposite and i kept doing
backhands with the wrong stick but i
didn't have a post on that one your
backhand was lethal because you had a
right-handed stick everybody thought you
were right-handed and he's going down
and going look at this [ __ ] guy he's
got like all these shots in the neck and
he's playing left-handed with a
right-handed stick was all right yeah
yeah i know man no you're good man
you're you're you're good at it i i was
oh thank you i was hoping you're going
to say something you know because i'm a
little self-conscious
i definitely recognized it
i skate all right until i get the puck i
just i swear to god dude it's just it
all falls apart you know what's the
funniest thing when i play with guys
it's two passes
to me and before you're fun
before my whole team figures it out and
then it's just like you know i then i
have to be like literally going across
the blue line screaming believe in me
something to get the [ __ ] puck back
but they know
no but you did you you had some good
passes shot on goal there was a i liked
playing david was a 13 year old kid
there there was a 14 year old kid there
and these and i just was like but i
almost hurt myself remember i slammed my
head dude yeah that was bad i was like
no i knew you were going to be so
everyone's saying hey go take some advil
and you're like nah dude i feel fine i
feel fine and when you fall like the way
you were falling those are those deep
[ __ ] bruises and they don't show up
for at least 24 hours the best thing
bruce did he goes dude you don't want a
concussion and he brings me a helmet and
i slip back oh dude if you if the way
you fell on my head dude that would i
would have been over oh yeah that would
have that awful
that [ __ ] sound of a head hitting the
back of a head hitting the ice oh my god
i felt so bad one time somebody's
skating by i thought it was you somebody
just goes you got air on that one like i
was getting the [ __ ] kicked out of me
but this is the thing though you are
doing it to yourself just let people
know it's not like people were knocking
them down this was a non-contact game
paul would just go head of [ __ ] steam
like you were gonna run i've never
played something i never the best
compliment i got was when i somebody
goes i go i never played ice hockey
before and it was like wow you got good
balance and i was like have you been
watching yeah i know right hey let me
let me do uh advertising we got some uh
we got some great questions uh this week
uh
all right stamps.com everybody i know
it's tough deciding where to focus your
resources to grow your business but one
thing i can tell you you don't need to
waste valuable time going to the post
office for mailing and shipping just use
stamps.com to access all the services of
the post office right from your desk 24
7. buy and print official us postage
using your own computer and printer get
postage for any letter or package any
class of mail all for just a fraction of
the cost of an expensive postage meter
with stamps.com you'll never have to go
to the post office again so you can
spend your time where it matters most
focused on your business i use
stamps.com to send out all my dvds my
t-shirts my posters paul whatever crap
i'm selling at the end of one of my
little dances uh right now
use my last name bur b-u-r-r for this
special offer no risk trial plus 110
bonus offer that includes a digital
scale and up to 55 dollars free postage
don't wait go to stamps.com before you
do anything else you click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in bur that's stamps.com enter
bur dude i [ __ ] killed that one
um evoice now that i said that now i'm
gonna be in my head watch this one all
right regroup okay we still got another
half to play
okay
i just don't mess it up
e-voice you're a business owner but
automated phone systems and secretaries
are not in your budget just yet and
juggling incoming calls yourself makes
it hard to look like a professional
here's something that will dramatically
help you make more money in 2014 e-voice
whether you're a business of one or 100
e-voice will help you manage all of your
incoming calls with a toll-free number
dial by name directory and call routing
tools your business will sound like a
million bucks can't take a call no
problem e-voice will transcribe the
voicemail and email it right to you
never be caught off guard again and with
e-voice you can try it before you buy it
right now just for my listeners you can
get a 60-day trial to e-voice for
absolutely free go to evoice.com and
enter the promo code bill bill at
checkout take charge of your business
and make more money in 2014 go to
evoice.com and enter bill at checkout
for your 60-day free trial that's
evoice.com promo code bill
damn that wasn't bad killing it crushing
it one more people
uh here we go legalzoom if the
excitement of starting your business
getting your first customer and finally
quitting your job hasn't moved you to
action yet here's another great reason
to get started it's national start your
business month everybody
that legal soup wants to help you start
your own corporation or llc or file a
dba so you can get up and running
quickly and easily find out why more
than one million entrepreneurs use
legalzoom to start down the path of
successful business ownership this month
only take advantage of their national
start your business month special and
get a free three-month trial of the
all-new quick books making it so much
easier to run your new business that's a
hundred nineteen dollar value for
absolutely free when you enter bur in
the referral box at checkout that's
legalzoom.com promo code burr legalzoom
provides
legalzoom provides self-help services
and can connect you with the right
attorney but they are not a law firm
legalzoom promo code burr
there you go i went you know i'm up two
games to one
um all right back to the uh back to the
the podcast here oh before i go any
further everybody um one of my favorite
comics
that's on his way up the comedy ladder
uh tom segura from uh the uh your mom's
house podcast right here on the all
things comedy network that he does with
his lovely and absolutely [ __ ]
hilarious wife christina presents
pizzitsky
i'm the worst trying to read um tom has
a new special outcome completely normal
that you can download as of march 15th
on itunes um i love this guy because
he's just one of those he doesn't give a
[ __ ] in a good way like he goes out he's
not afraid of silence he has something
to say dude him and his wife arguably
okay i know burns and allen [ __ ] them
okay
you want to go with these two they crush
it like we have like those all things
comedy shows sometimes um we were doing
them down at luna
and uh and christina came down one night
and absolutely just [ __ ] destroyed
i'm trying to think we had we had tom
down there too i've watched tommy like
the improv forever but um
he's the real deal and he's on his way
to making his mark uh and he has a new
uh new uh comedy special like i said
completely normal so check it out
all right
first question of the week and paul i
know you're gonna love this one because
you've been absolutely obsessed with
this uh this says the the name of the
question is where's the plane oh yeah
let's go
uh he says bill using whatever knowledge
you have of the situation whether it be
a lot or a little please break down what
happened on that plane
um this is right up my alley first of
all it's right up here i've been
annoying you and you yeah and you hate
flying i tell you and we know it's
annoying is i have to blow my nose
because i'm coming on with the cold so
why don't you start as i walk over here
to blow my nose off mike because i'm a
professional what do you think paul
you're the guest i'll let you go first
here would you like a glass
go ahead what do you think uh i think
that
i think obviously the plane was hijacked
i think that's why the um
the uh
you know it's hard to
no uh i hear that on on um yeah a little
bit i think the plane was hijacked um
of course i think that's why there was
the communication was cut out and then
they have proof that it kind of
uh diverted and and changed its course
and nobody heard anything i think the
fact that the [ __ ] thing is not in
the water there's 230 people on a 777. i
flew that i've flown in a 777 to uh
italy oh yeah your nickname 777.
yeah i mean so i fly it no um and and
and there was i won't go unless it's a
seven it's not a seven yeah it's not
it's glass it's class the whole way it's
a lucky number you know okay you think
i've been at 737
no so uh
so there was no debris nothing so i
don't think that the i think that the
plane they said that the plane could
have flown for six hours after they lost
contact that [ __ ] thing could be
anywhere right now there's gonna be a
movie about this i think
i hope they didn't off everybody you
know god god forbid but i think the
plane landed somewhere and was hidden
and then i think the people that did it
i think i don't know what i don't know
what they did with the people but uh you
know i don't think it's in the ocean
side all right let's you know come on
you got to put some money on well listen
i don't know what country you're picking
kazakhstan
they said it could have gone as far as
kazakhstan to zika stand all of those
stands
uh i am from
kazakhstan i i think uh
yeah dude i think that it landed
somewhere and it's [ __ ] it's just an
awful situation but um you know i i this
is what i think it's the aliens built
you think
i don't know i think uh
with each day that passes that there's
no sort of demand or anything like that
i'm thinking more
unfortunately and i don't know
sadistically or whatever
they flew it way off course and
i don't know i mean how
unless you dump a plane in like the
shipping lanes what is what is the odds
the planes have a beacon planes have a
beacon but it was turned off
i i mean i don't know there's something
that that where they can track it was
[ __ ] turned off
and the people knew how to do it
so i think with every passing day yeah
like it's not a good like that there's
no demands it's just really weird that
that if you know there's always some
crazy reason to draw attention to
something that someone does something
like this the fact the only hope that i
have is the fact that they haven't asked
for any demands
yet is is i i don't know that i mean
what you wanted the plane
i mean what the [ __ ] you know how [ __ ]
up is your country you can't get a 777
christ they're laying all over the place
but what's the motive what's the motive
of the hijackers
uh i don't know but i i really felt for
the the family members because they're
sitting there and they're talking about
the airline how the airline is handling
this like a a business
rather than
you know what is going on and they go we
can't comment on anything right now
because basically you know it's a
corporation they're like we're gonna get
the [ __ ] suit out of us let's let's try
to limit how much we're gonna get the
[ __ ] suited like they go into that
[ __ ] mode yeah
but it's one of those awful things where
you know um
also you know the victims
are gonna go into we're going to sue the
[ __ ] out of your mode so it's just like
if people could just
in this moment
if the airline could be allowed to just
say we're [ __ ] devastated i mean we
had employees on that plane
too you know and they could everybody
could just share information
and there wouldn't be that stupid you
know lawyers licking their chops on both
sides or one cowering and the other guy
other side licking their chops maybe
they they could at least make it a
little more comforting for those people
but uh
and it's in and yeah i guess there's no
comedy here dude that's just it's
[ __ ] i just feel i just feel i just
feel bad for you know those kids on
there and [ __ ] man it's [ __ ] up man
it's awful and it's one of the most
unprecedented uh
mysteries
like a 777 with [ __ ] 230 people's
disappeared and nobody knows where it is
and the airlines don't have answers
and 10 countries had their navies
[ __ ] just scout at the [ __ ] ocean
and nobody could find it right it's
crazy man well i mean there's a kind of
good thing there that maybe what they're
they're still alive and there's
something you can do to negotiate but
the thing about uh
trying to land a plane like that it's
not like you could just go to some boot
bootleg [ __ ] airstrip i mean you need
to you need a lot of [ __ ] runway to
land something that big it's not like
you could go to [ __ ] right
you know some little ass you know unless
they had it planned unless they had it
planned in a hangar yeah but then what
what the [ __ ] so what are you doing so
you okay you got it you took the [ __ ]
plane you took the people what do you
want
where are the people it's annoying i
mean they think
i mean i wonder if if they had a plan
and then something they shut everything
off and then something else went wrong
how i mean because they got to be
looking at satellite footage like say
even like remote areas jungles and [ __ ]
looking for pictures of smoke and fire
something to try and find the [ __ ]
thing i mean look
the biggest mystery still on the planet
is the ocean so i think that that's
where it is it's at the bottom of the
[ __ ] ocean in some place where we
can't find i hope it isn't but that's
what i would guess just for the simple
fact that it's just weird that nobody
claimed responsibility
there's no ransom demands
uh i mean how do you sneak a [ __ ] 777
into something
with the amount of fuel they had they
know the distance it could go there had
to be something dude there had to be
something the fact that it's not it
should be on every [ __ ] like it i
don't think that there's enough coverage
of it you know they got a picture you
know what they what the [ __ ] they
probably would be a lot well at some
point when there's no new information
becomes like this [ __ ]
250 270 person cold case file
they're trying to trying to find it's
insane it's [ __ ] insane it is it is
and and that's why i kept asking you
every day we'd go hang out and bill
would go paul i can't [ __ ] you keep
talking about it and i'm like i can't
get it i don't get it because you you
got this obsession with [ __ ] planes
and safety you know because you're
afraid to fly it i don't [ __ ] think
about [ __ ] like that and now your fear
is starting to rub off me i'm getting
scared when i go to the airport
i didn't mean to project my fears on you
it's okay you're only human
all right
uh whatever i i really hope that that
ends you know i hope doesn't yeah
there's some sort of chuck norris delta
force thing that ends it [ __ ] happily
but
that is a rough city oh my god the
[ __ ] poor people they got to
sit there wondering when when what's
going on are they suffering now what's
going on it's terrible it's awful all
right great question buddy
all right what's your beef
dear farmer bill
if you could only eat one type of meat
and one type of vegetable for the rest
of your life what would they be gotta
figure some choices are more versatile
in the kitchen
all right uh i wouldn't go fish because
i would worry that i'd get the mercury
thing
um i couldn't go red meat because i end
up like john wayne chicken is all slimy
in your [ __ ] entrails i would have to
go uh
what else is there turkey
i go turkey i'd go chicken because if
you cook it if you cook it enough like
you'll get any kind of but yeah you're
right the mercury and the fish red meat
your bowel you're [ __ ] working the
fish and god knows what that meltdown in
japan has done to the [ __ ] sushi
jesus oh i had sushi yesterday man [ __ ]
yeah yeah i love [ __ ] sushi you know
yeah you know yeah you know
you're not getting a sushi but uh no
i'll go chicken and vegetable i hate
vegetables so i managed maybe spinach a
little garlic
you know i love vegetables
oh that would actually make a chicken
pot sad like this is like [ __ ] sad
so i guess i would have turkey every day
with uh
i almost want to pick a vegetable that i
don't love because i don't want to end
up hating it because i have to eat it
every day
cauliflower every day for really [ __ ]
i already hate that [ __ ] no cauliflowers
unless they make the cauliflower mashed
potatoes those are those aren't bad but
the only reason why it's not bad is
because you've got all the butter and
salt and pepper in there yeah but yeah i
mean i would go turkey because i could
make a turkey sandwich i could make
turkey sausage i could make shrimp this
shrimp that like we saw that guy
montreal i know
that actor we were in the elevator with
bubba
bubba gump and i i didn't wreck i only
saw that movie once
yeah i walked in there and i was like oh
[ __ ] no he walked out you know who that
was dude i was like yeah he was in heat
he was that was funny he was funny
he was funny and insanely friendly
and uh and then i wanted to go up and
say something or invite him to his show
and i was just like let me [ __ ] leave
this guy along
you said you saw another there was a
bunch of people they were filming a
movie in a hotel
turkey bacon
try to think all the different [ __ ]
ways i could do it well you wouldn't go
turkey turkey you'd be a nightmare after
your fifth turkey sandwich you'd be like
i [ __ ] up dude after chicken every
[ __ ] day
chicken chicken parmesan uh chicken
scampi you're doing what i just did
chicken chicken chicken
turkey sandwich turkey sausage i'm
talking you could put marinara with
melted mozzarella that's [ __ ] that's
good for a month
you know that's every [ __ ] day you'd
be a tough [ __ ]
you'd be a tub of [ __ ] dude do you need
chicken palm every other day
you wouldn't be a tub of [ __ ] if you eat
chicken every day you know you gotta
make it a palm with all the pasta and
all that
[ __ ] bread your red wine discussing
crimes whatever you sicilians do
[Laughter]
i guess i would go turkey
i love a turkey sandwich and i think
chicken's overrated and then just the
[ __ ] that you know chickens you know you
got the salmonella you got all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] with that you know oh
there's a problem with everything
we know paul maybe have a problem with
you you ever think
that no
i'd go chicken spinach
chicken spinach i would go turkey
yeah the turkey really doesn't go good
with a vegetable
chicken spinach is a good one
fat christ paul you're better at this
than i am
all right dude you're you're [ __ ] you
committed some crazy [ __ ] murder yeah
you're on death row you got your final
meal what are you going to have
oh
oh [ __ ] man
let me tell you that's a rough one you
know
that's so funny you asked me that i'd
like to actually lean back in the chair
for that one that's a that's tough this
is assuming you could eat i'm so
nauseous that they're gonna [ __ ] kill
me here yeah i never understood that
they showed a list of what all the
serial killers got and like one guy like
one guy like bundy or one of those guys
just got an apple but another guy got
[ __ ] like he wanted a whole pie with
like pepperoni he wanted sandwiches and
like he got the whole thing like he just
like everything that's a true [ __ ]
crazy man
yeah to be able to sit you know he's at
a food court like the guy eating an
apple he's probably just like let me
just taste one last thing let's have fun
he was a [ __ ] i don't know if it was
bundy it might have been that mcveigh
guy that blew timothy mcveigh and i
remember this he didn't have he got a
pint of mint chocolate chip and that
stuck with me because i was like i love
mint chocolate chip and i eat a pint all
the time and that actually seemed like
if someone was gonna [ __ ] kill me and
i don't have any sympathy for these
[ __ ] people either but i'm just
saying if someone's gonna kill me
you know it would and i know
you know we're [ __ ] going to kill you
at this time and it's coming up i want
something that's going to be a little
easy on my stomach and for some reason i
just think ice cream would be nice
dude i love i love chicken cutlets man
like i know like my mind well right when
you ask a question i'm thinking italian
or sushi because i love it but i love
chicken cutlets with lemon squeezed on
them so i might do like a shitload of
chicken cookies you just said chicken
and i just thought chicken and dumplings
which i haven't had long-term better
than dumplings dumplings are great
chicken and dumplings and that but then
the mint chocolate chips they wouldn't
go good with the diet did they let you
drink did i let you drink on what like
on your last meal if you ordered a
bottle of red because that would be
funny if you were hammered
all right what do you got
let's do this
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] you you guys are looking
who you're gonna kill the kill you
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah you got enough
guys
[Laughter]
all my marriages were one-on-one look at
you guys five on one
what are the odds
oh you feel good about yourself i don't
think you feel successful
hang your head on this one
[Music]
i don't think they let them drink that'd
be [ __ ] great why you guys all have
the same clothes on
would you all call each other
making the other psychos laughing as
you're leaving
show me the way to go home that judge
was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's what you would do you would just
start talking [ __ ] yeah he did good
it only took his eight years
you go into the death chamber and all
the [ __ ] family members are looking
ah you guys do stuff too
the only difference between me and you
is i got caught that's all i'm saying
how you doing sweetheart
[Laughter]
that'd be [ __ ] amazing oh dude that'd
be hilarious
just walking out hey buddy buddy before
you do it buddy you know the way i keep
asking the question but anyway
it only took you five years i had those
hookers in the attic forever
this is so bad
hey did you uh there was there's been a
couple of guys uh you know some of the
last words one of the guys go with his
last name was french and he yelled over
the reporters he goes hey and he was
going to the electric chair he goes hey
he goes i got your your headline for
tomorrow he goes french fries
he's like
like laughs and then they electrocuted
him dude you see the one guy that they
did it to and he [ __ ] they thought he
was frightening he [ __ ] he popped up
and he was like [ __ ] he popped up
like in a [ __ ] horror movie he was
like a big guy and it did he didn't it
didn't take they electrocuted them and
they're all sitting there is that that
tom hanks movie that really happened no
no a guy they showed it on they showed
it on one of those shows where they
jolted them and like normally like the
normal person what show and he just went
it was like one of those death throw in
me or like it was like a you know people
protesting outside one of the guys i
thought you were dead on discovery
and he like popped up for a second and
they [ __ ] up part two
no i'm telling you
scared the [ __ ] out of the face you
gotta make sure they're dead you know
got a friend of mine you can electrocute
him
right now you can take a beating oh this
guy's rough okay
why they put him in the point of the
electric chair he got right back up okay
boy i got a freddy's tough
i wish i was tougher
we all do
we're not high people we're not drunk
this is what if i was if i was hiring
i'll be [ __ ] losing my mind all right
uh sad music oh
it's right up our alley
why'd you bring it up all right sad
music dear bill
uh from what you talk about on the
from what you talk about on the podcast
it seems like
you're mostly into classic rock and
music that involves really talented
musicians uh do you ever listen to
emotional music i mean like a sad
acoustic track
or just anything depressing
versus already losing it if so do you
put it on when you're sad or when you're
happy no no no i i listen to that stuff
sometimes i like to get emotional when
i'm in the car
what's up what song are we singing in
the car just once i'm gonna try to make
it lasting forever just one night
try to do something else and something
something something yes we were doing
we were saying we'd say that to our
wives one time when they were like
bitching
how come you blah blah blah blah blah
blah that's in the middle of them
yelling just stare at them and just go
just once
i wish you'd shut the [ __ ] up
why does there always have to be
something to do
can't we just lie around the house just
one you know paul you creep you keep
procrastinating and you sleep in late
and the kids are up
just once
i wish you'd let me sleep in
shut your
mouth
you [ __ ] talk all the
time you have nothing to say
lady all right sorry um
sad music do i listen to sad music yeah
probably the first sad songs i listened
to
other than elton john where he was a
little too on the head what do you
consider sad though like that's what i
wanted ac dc ride on lonely guy on the
road that was probably my first one dude
every [ __ ] heavy metal band
had those home sweet homes
i'll tell you what's sad you want to
know what's a sad one that we never
we're halfway there
[Laughter]
yeah uh no i don't i you know what's a
sad song um
i don't know
cats in the cradle
you go right you're going rock though
i'm thinking more of like the just once
like you know oh you can't go hip-hop
hip-hop you can't do a sad song they try
to do emotional rap remember that yeah
and some people still try yeah like when
it when what that guy drake man i just
like i don't i mean i get it yeah you
know good looking guy he's got a beard
and [ __ ] so women like him but like when
it just gets too uh
i don't want to hear like
i don't hear a rapper opening up no
rappers try to open up when one of their
rapper friends dies but it's never
really sad you're more just like you
know they'll just be like you know
they're just rapping you know what
they're doing they're pouring out of 40
for them that's like the most they'll do
i like that they keep it like that okay
nobody was better than you like it's
like that you can't get you know you
know one of my favorite things in this
business was opie from the opium anthony
show
was he had this thing that he would do
when guys would start crying when they
would play audio yeah oh my god it was
[ __ ] his timing was perfect every
time someone would be talking like
retiring from a sport
like when mike schmidt retired which is
you know it's very difficult to watch he
was like you know
you know he just was ending his like 38
years ago
a little boy began a journey
to play the wonderful game of baseball
okay and then opie would always go oh
boy
one of my favorite and always oh boy it
always made oh god that's great nobody
wants to see a man just completely
you know what it is i can watch a guy
cry if something terrible is happening
just don't try to talk
while you're crying no that's the thing
the talking and then bursting out into
crying just let your shoulders go yeah
you're [ __ ] crying but don't [ __ ] for
the love of god a man needs to cry a man
needs to cry in private yeah you do that
in the shower you do it in the shower
like when my son was born everyone's
like did you cry it and i'm like no what
are you talking about and then when my
son was born it all hit me later and i
went home to go get stuff for my wife in
the hospital and i sat on the couch and
i didn't like weep but i just got i
can't
i didn't weep but i got emotional but
i'm just picking you sitting on the
couch by yourself and just usually
look at that stupid face
it's just completely unacceptable to use
your thing from your podcast uh that's
unexpected
it's unacceptable dude on it completely
no you're right though the talk into it
right yeah the talk into it that's
that's what the funny thing about crying
is you know yeah you know you always do
this to me you know you always do this
to me and i'm trying my best and it's
just it's over yeah it's [ __ ] over
whenever my friends die i've had so many
who [ __ ] died i just cry in the
shower yeah that's what i do i asked a
girl we asked a girl right because you
don't feel like you're crying because
there's all that water on your face
anyways
no we asked the girl we go what would
you do if your dude started crying like
if it was if nobody died if a dude and
you were just arguing he just had a bad
day and he just had a bad day and you
got into it and he broke down and cried
and she goes yeah no over over over
get the [ __ ] away from me yeah you know
what's funny there's some women they
think that they want to see that part of
you they don't what that is to them is
that's their total conquest
like you know when you bang a girl in
the ass you're just like yeah i got this
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ] with it
their version of that
is is if they can get you to be so
vulnerable around them that you cry and
then it's one of those things it's
almost like when the crowd screams out a
joke they already heard they think they
want to hear it again and then you tell
it's like ah yeah that wasn't as good no
it's the same thing as that
yeah and you said something you said
something about like if a burglar comes
in if you cry in front of a woman all in
her mind is like what if the burger
comes in at this [ __ ] guy yeah no
it's over you can't cry
you strip a woman of security if you cry
in front of her i think i don't think
i've cried i think my wife's yeah that's
a great that's what it is yeah you
stripper of her security because now
she's like well i got this [ __ ] yeah
this very crisis got this baby sleeping
next to you every night
you know yeah it's it's over you know
what i mean oh yeah no you just you
might as well just have a pull over
sweater on
you know
walking around and then she mocks you
what are you going to cry [ __ ]
you're so mean
yeah it's [ __ ] over dude
you can't have that uh so sad music uh
cats in the cradle with classic one uh
no i actually listen to a lot of i but
believe it or not like i mean you always
have like your core
[ __ ] that you listen i like to feel i
like some phil collins
when it's sad
what is it yeah i wish it would rain
down
down well i hated that annoying one when
he was sitting there like ruining my day
by bringing up homeless people like i
don't look at them and feel bad for them
yeah no which one was a day for you and
me
oh
think twice cause it's just another day
for you and me you and me in paradise
[Applause]
yeah yeah that [ __ ] stupid song
yeah no i hate when people do unless all
the money to that went to homeless
people that's one that's just pandering
to them have you ever have you ever
cried alone listening to a song or like
got not cried but have you ever been
like oh no i've completely broken down
and i've totaled three cars
just weeping uncontrollably
[Laughter]
no no i've definitely teared up
listen as an artist at some point you're
gonna have to go to those emotions you
need you need to be uh you need to be in
tune with your instrument no i have
what was the ones like i had this weird
thing where um
i stopped crying at some point
i don't know when i stopped crying and
got mad more when i got hurt and my
brother beat the [ __ ] out of me um
you know that with it most of the crying
i'd be just like [ __ ] you at the end of
it but i wasn't but i wasn't crying
and then
i didn't cry
i remember one time dude
i remember one time my my brother's
bigger than me my little brother's
bigger than me right big though like
and i remember he i said i said if you
[ __ ] take my clothes again if you
take my clothes again he did it every
day he would go into my room and take my
belt he would take my clothes and i'd
come home and you guys in a boy band and
i i need to go i need to go out right
and i go mom if he does it again i'm
[ __ ] hitting him and my mom be like
oh you know he did and he and one time i
need really needed a shirt and i'm
[ __ ] throwing [ __ ] through the house
and he gets out of his friend's car and
he starts walking up and he's got it on
and i [ __ ] snapped him my grandmother
was there and i jumped on him and i
started punching him and he stood up and
he just goes
[ __ ] you
[Music]
wait you made your older brother cry i
know my younger brother oh he was bigger
than me but he didn't know what to do he
got so upset that he just and he looked
around he just he was so angry that
something needed to come out he just
goes
[ __ ] you
what did you feel bad did you start
laughing no i i kind of just walked away
and you know we laughed about it
afterwards but now now he's he's a [ __ ]
he's a big kid but you know my mom had
the opposite i got a little brother man
he's an animal you know no my mom said
she went to she went to a funeral once
and everybody was there and everybody
was crying and she was overwhelmed with
emotion that they had to [ __ ] drag
her out she said she had one of the most
embarrassing things happened to her
where she said she uncontrollably
laughed
because they said that that could happen
sometimes so she's sitting there
she's sitting there and everybody's
crying and like she went up and she
could not stop laughing
and like she and i said why like and she
was like paul i just don't know she goes
i could not stop laughing and i had to
walk me out and like and she just she's
mom yeah she said because the emotions
were so much that they said that that
could happen sometimes
where it just you just like she didn't
know what to do so instead of just
breaking down she went the other way and
just couldn't couldn't control herself
yeah like humans like will protect you
in uh a really
like that's what they don't get
sometimes when comics make [ __ ]
horrific jokes about some bad event make
good jokes yeah it's about a horrific
event so they go that's so [ __ ] me
it's a defense mechanism
my mom my mom was a sweetheart who felt
bad and her emotions just went the other
way and she goes paul i felt so bad i
couldn't control myself
so i couldn't control myself i hate to
say this because somebody lost somebody
but there was if there was video of that
oh my god
oh i was saying so i somewhere around i
don't know 10 or 11 i didn't cry
for years
years and years and years and i didn't i
didn't cry until a friend of mine killed
himself and even then
i was sad and it just i went uh i was in
the bathroom once again
yeah and it was in there
and i remember i started to cry and then
i started thinking like wow i'm crying
i've been crying a long time and then i
stopped because i was out of it because
i stopped thinking about the dude
killing himself
wow
yeah i went 10 years without a cry and
then i had one
what was it over
yogurt
they didn't have gummy bears
[Laughter]
no uh i think yeah i might even i might
have been when my son was born you know
i might have been on my side that's
that's acceptable i guess it's
acceptable back in the day you just
stood out in the waiting room right
smoked a cigar no you irish dudes don't
cry i said today i even just tweeted
something irish dudes i swear to god
i've never seen a funnier group of
people who ate take pain and just take a
beating some of the funniest people to
talk to the acceptance it seeks it's the
acceptance
of the beating and you don't try to
change it you just like you just keep
running into the brickwork there's
something so comical about just
accepting the beating not trying to
remedy it at all i don't i don't have
that 100 anymore because of getting into
this business and traveling and yeah
seeing other types of ways of dealing
with [ __ ] but like dude i was actually
thinking the other day like my bloodline
german irish scottish english right
there i mean that would make a therapist
do a spit take like you're [ __ ]
emotionally when you have that blood
running through you i don't know what it
is and then uh well i see you when we
get hung over and we had a night out the
night before and then i see you in the
lobby and you just see the look on my
face and i'm miserable and i'm looking
at him and i'm going this guy did what i
did how is he just taking it like you
don't even show you just [ __ ] put
your head down and go me i put that's
how i got sick
yeah because we we out we found that uh
that cigar private place we smoked the
cigars in calgary we drank we got like
three hours sleep and we woke up came
here
yeah took a [ __ ] steam and then i
came back and like an [ __ ] well i'm
gonna go work out
oh three hours of sleep and then i
[ __ ] jumped on the treadmill and then
worked out and i came back and then
right when i got to the theater and my
head i was going like like this is dumb
bill yeah don't go down to the treadmill
cause you just got all taught in the
steam thing and then you're gonna run
down this sweating and you only got
three hours you go version what'd you do
i go i took a nap i laid down it was
great i go what'd you do you go did you
get some sleep he goes no no i went to
the gym like it's a [ __ ] animal
give yourself a break yeah i i i go
until i get sick and then i give myself
a break whatever paul hey what do you
want from me okay i am who i am okay i
got a friend who doesn't quit you know
hey sometimes i want to i'm just afraid
you're sabotaging yourself
it's obnoxious at this point people and
i don't care [ __ ] you you do 20 days on
the road all right problem with
ex-girlfriend um bill uh i have a
question regarding how to handle a
situation with my ex-girlfriend i used
to really hug kiss and squeeze her all
the time after we broke up i talked to a
pretty 20 year old in a coffee shop
about squeezing and making out in the
blue water in thailand she really got
into it and asked me to show her how i
would pleasure her in the ladies room
dude this guy's got some game he's
sitting there paid in a picture to the
point
there you go
he goes i have always been a romantic so
i said yes that's hilarious i'm a
romantic i'll take you to the ladies
room oh my god [ __ ] movie
i kind of got into eating around i don't
get this graphic you guys i added some
dirty talk and i think somebody might
have listened in i saw my ex-girlfriend
leave the copy wait she was in there
later but she did not say hello
wait a minute i i got with the
graphicness of this
wait wait wait i talked to in a coffee
shop
she was really into it so wait wait wait
wait wait so i saw my ex-girlfriend
leave the coffee shop so she was there
as you did all of this but she didn't
say hello
i met up with this girl a couple times
and she always wanted to play me to
pleasure her in public places like the
movies etc she got a fetish here then
she suddenly proposed that i would
pleasure her friend who i had met a
couple of times dude [ __ ] you what this
is awesome dude you don't have to
achieve [ __ ] it was a coffee shop all
right
i know from experience that this would
be a red flag but i said yes because i
am 42. oh now he's a creep
42 what are you doing he's still out
there
and i really the longer this question
goes the more it sounds like a lie yeah
i know right and i really love to
pleasure women after having pleasured
this woman in a changing room in a
department store i again saw my
ex-girlfriend leaving without saying
hello where dude this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] you keep pleasuring this woman
and your girlfriend keeps showing up and
up i don't buy it uh but i gotta read
this is such a great story i'm gonna
finish it though
um later my ex-girlfriend called me and
was a bit upset she asked me am i not a
woman you would have sex in a public
place with
now the correct grammar would be a woman
with whom you would have sex in a public
place do you think i should correct your
grammar uh this is all a [ __ ] one or
would you think that correcting her is a
sign of not being over her
i i don't buy that man that's just too
[ __ ] crazy i mean that was that's
like i've never heard of anything yeah
and he's 42. that was very well written
phony question and i liked all the
[ __ ] left turns it was wonderful i
enjoyed it there's no way that could be
real right no
not not
i mean you're sitting in a [ __ ]
coffee shop when your ex-girlfriend's
sitting there not saying hi and another
kid and she doesn't work at the coffee
shop and another girl's like hey man why
don't you come in the bathroom and eat
me out i mean that's like
listen that alone that could happen but
to then have it happen again at
thailand you know what i mean
the department store i heard a lucky
play the lotto buddy jesus
um all right this is the last one and
then we got it we gotta run here um am i
a [ __ ]
uh hey there billy fat face [ __ ] you
i've been on the treadmill uh i am a
senior in high school and might be a
[ __ ]
i know you're the lean mean redheaded
machine when it comes to calling out
[ __ ] so i'll let you be the judge i
hate listen
i i don't [ __ ] judge you here
all right my ex-boyfriend who was a year
older than me left for college at the
end of last year he goes to university
of washington a decent leap from arizona
where we went to high school we broke up
after dating just over a year because we
ultimately agreed that a long-distance
relationship would suck for both of us
plus i eventually knew i'd be plagued
with the thought of him balls deep in
some artsy [ __ ] and it would get to me
this girl's hilarious
however when we visited this uh for his
winter break about six months later i
came on to him again he initially didn't
want to get back together because he
knew he was leaving and thought i'd be
uh
i'd be hurt in the long run but quickly
gave in we were basically dating again
for the entire three week break he was
here holding hands in public and going
on dates where one of us would pay or
the other
um
what do we got here finally we left
without any incident but it felt like we
kind of flashed back to our heavily
involved relationship here's where
things start to get sleazy on my part
his friend devin uh oh oh boy was always
around oh boy
oh boy his friend devon was always
around when we were dating trying to
insert himself into things when my ex
and i would hang out my ex thought it
was creepy and shut him down but ever
since he left i've been hanging out with
devon a lot oh how could you do this all
the dicks in the world you're going to
jump on this one
which would make you a [ __ ] it just
kind of makes you like uh you could have
had a better selection here here we go
i spent valentine's day with them and
then she writes you oh geez
uh but nothing happened and i sent my ex
a picture to see what his reaction be
that's what she's doing it upset him and
he told me that it really pissed him off
and was comparable to cheating later
this month i went to a formal event with
him and posed posted a picture on
twitter i texted my ex later
that week and he told me it was really
pissing him off how i dragged him back
into having feelings for me and then rub
my proverbial dick in his face i
apologize but ever since then he seemed
kind of pissed at me and interest and
not interested in talking to me what do
you think that billy boy am i a dirty
[ __ ] and
is his just anger justified or is he
just being a jealous [ __ ] love the
podcast thanks and go [ __ ] yourself um
you're not a [ __ ]
you're not a dirty [ __ ] uh what you are
is you're being a really mean person
because you don't know how to express
the fact that you still have feelings
for him so you dragged him back into it
and maybe um you didn't want to break up
with them
but you or maybe you thought you did and
now you're having second thoughts about
it and rather than just saying that to
him
uh the pain you have that you're not
together you're now sort of for some
reason taking it out on him
by doing everything that you know
is going to tear his heart out of his
chest so you need to stop doing that
that's what i would say yeah that's
exactly like it's like
just nobody how come nobody just picks
up the phone and says hey like keep
sending the poor guy pictures and
[ __ ] doing that to them there's no
look they're young they're young you
don't know you don't know how to do
stuff like that and sometimes you're
doing [ __ ] and you don't know why you're
doing [ __ ] because you don't know who
you are yet so i'm not judging this
person i'm just saying what you're doing
is really it's really unnecessarily mean
but one thing that's not brought up what
about devin's feelings
i know he must really seem to care for
her no but like there's two guys getting
[ __ ] she's sending pictures i don't
know just i mean listen without a doubt
devin
devin's not a good dude
because it's his friend it's his friend
yeah
and he was trying to move in on it when
uh
when uh when they were still together so
that guy
you know it's weird you know who's going
to lose in all of this is going to be
you because you're you're with this
creep this guy's a [ __ ] creep
um or maybe he's just well you know
you don't know he's a creep though maybe
maybe he always had feelings for her and
the other guy didn't treat we don't know
i just went with creep but she said that
her ex-boyfriend said it was creepy i
don't [ __ ] know paul what am i going
to solve
solve the problems of [ __ ] 18 and 19
year olds i can't do this all right look
yeah stop doing that to him stop posting
let me know and you're you're acting
like you don't know what you're doing at
least as far as like uh hurting the
person you're hurting you're hurting
them and you should stop
um and if you don't then you're a mean
person you're not a [ __ ]
she's not a horror no that's not a [ __ ]
that's not a [ __ ] what is the word of
you paul
if she sent pictures while she was
blowing devin i mean i'd be a little
[ __ ] much
you know but even then as you get older
when you start to think of the psycho
psychological reasons as to why a woman
would do that
you know and it always goes back to some
sort of family issue that they would do
that some sort of insecurity and you
know having no boundaries a lot of times
when something like that happens you got
touched as a kid i'm kind of
paraphrasing some of the [ __ ] that i've
heard some no i just think when i think
of [ __ ] i think of you
using sex
you you know doing sexual things or
using sex in order to to gain and do
stuff like that you know to to get
yourself ahead through through sex right
and [ __ ] and i would actually say that
that's more of a sociopath who just
happens to be using
uh
you know sex rather than using a gun or
a knife or something like that they're
just going up they're using the weapon
that they got are all horror sociopaths
no no no no no no no i would say i would
say no not at all i would say that you
know
men and women who have a bunch of
[ __ ] partner different partners or
something like that the older i get
they're not like
dogs and [ __ ] and stuff like that like
they have there's something wrong with
them uh
beyond um
look there's something wrong with
[ __ ] being married and this is the
only person you're gonna have sex with
again i mean that's just there's
something not [ __ ] natural about that
but the other side of that is to just
walk around
[ __ ] everybody just [ __ ] everybody
then there's something there's something
wrong about that but what i'm doing is
also
you know my opinion is is i'm coming i'm
looking out my own head here how i would
feel i remember you know
i was out dogging around i would always
feel like a piece of [ __ ] on some level
past a certain age
your 20s you're like psyched like yeah i
got another one right in your 30s it
starts to get it starts to get sad
starts to get pathetic so i wouldn't say
you're a [ __ ] but um
unfortunately we have to wrap up here
paul another effortless podcast
great time yeah it was always a great
time the versi effect podcast yes
diversity effect podcast and also um we
kick off march 31st at largo the all-in
tour yes all in tour with myself joe
bartnick jason lawhead um these three
animals are going on tour and uh i'm
gonna host the kickoff one it's not i
don't know yeah that one's getting that
one's to be at largo yeah i don't know
where the other ones are dates are
coming in dates are coming yeah west
coast states yes san francisco punchline
is on the website now so you could go to
that we're going to portland we're going
to seattle we're going to san diego east
coast will be in jersey uh we will be in
uh cleveland so check out yeah we're
gonna be in pittsburgh so check out all
those dates are coming in but that's the
all-in tour
with uh oh sponsored by the monday
morning
the first tour that i'm putting uh
putting the monday morning podcast name
behind and we appreciate it i know i
just love your talents
uh yeah so and now you could uh go uh to
my twitter at paul verzi that's
v-i-r-z-i and please uh download the
versi effect podcast bill was the last
guest on it